that just and I'm saying this with with  pride for what I do I'm not trying to  say here's my standing or where I want  to be in the [ __ ] business that's not  what I mean I mean that I want to be  good at it you know we all hello  Friedman Enterprises  that's the hotel phone  you have some fruit  some Celeste food no do you want some  sliced fruit I'm all good no we're good  thank you so much  all right all right bye-bye it's always  a fruit plate  everyone's always trying to hand you a  fruit plate in life you know it's a  pretty sweet thing if that was actually  like the CIA and they were actually  saying something else and this is I'm  just saying fake stuff about you want  some fruit yeah I want some fruit then  all of a sudden there's the Red Dot on  my head and yeah and the ceiling  disappears and the the ca was like wrap  it up wrap it up wrap it up wrap it up  you jump out the window and there's a  helicopter waiting